hey guys this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so
i've been working as a professional
trader for the past six years in hong
kong and
right now guys i'm doing youtube videos
because i want to show you guys how pro
traders actually working what kind of
tools and techniques
we use and most importantly how to use
them
so if you guys want to know about all
the stuff and if you want to know about
how we actually make money on the market
as pro traders you are in the right
place so today i want to talk about
fugo tv let's get into it
[Music]
so i can see that there is a lot of
interest in the stock because a lot of
you are actually asking me stuff in the
comments and stuff like this
i know that probably you guys bought it
too high and you're wondering what is
the right thing to do
should you buy this dip or not so the
answer is yes
but where should you buy it not at 28
not
definitely at 34 here so basically the
breakout we are in a situation a bit
different
because the most of the videos i do i
have here
this kind of trendline but fubu you know
broke it
and never actually restarted so actually
the trend line we have in here that is
the most
uh the strongest one is at 23. so we
have retested it once
and for now we are not retesting it but
guys this is the level so i'm not saying
we
gonna go there for sure i'm just saying
that you know this is if you are long
don't buy more at 28 29 30 you need to
wait
a bit longer a bit more so and we have
here the 200 period moving average that
is coming
and my scenario guys so you see i'm
mostly bullish on everything but doesn't
mean i'm bullish
at any level i would rate something like
this
all right so maybe here
visually it looks good on the 30s of
april so i guess we have time all right
we are not in a rush we have so i'm
doing this video on the 10th of march
guys maybe
you know i'm posting it a bit later the
reason is that you know i'm still
working as a trader
to work every day and i take some days
off to do my videos so i mostly do all
the videos the same day
and then i publish it uh daily on my
youtube channel so here
you have i think one month guys this
movie is strong all right guys you need
to understand
that this kind of moves uh they have
some momentum
when you have a strong move like this
you might have a rebound
but guys it's going to get sold again
all right and we need you need to have
this consolidation
i don't see any consolidation here guys
this is too fresh
i don't think this is the end of the
correction for fubu football is going to
correct more
at least in time maybe not in spot i'm
not 100 sure we're going to 23.
80 sure but this is enough for me to
actually wait
before making any move here if we go to
23 of course you average down guys you
buy more you buy more
and careful guys because we can break if
you break 23
and 20 you don't want to hear that but
it would be
wise to actually light a bit your
position
and b to be able to buy more lower but
we're not there yet guys for now 23 is a
strong support
uh i don't think we're gonna break it
i'm just saying guys how
we actually set up trades as pro traders
so
let's check quickly the short interest
on fubu see if it has
increased so i go on market watch 17
of short interest so it has not changed
so i know it increased a little bit it
was 16
17. maybe hedge funds are shorting the
stuff
probably by the way so you don't want to
go against them guys you need to wait
for some more
buying power to step in the game and
reverse this trend
and make some higher lows and higher
highs before entering your trade
so guys that's it for me i hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything new
and stay close to show i'll see you guys